this is a production of Cornell
University as Joyce mentioned I'm the
growth chamber supervisor for the
Cornell AG Experiment Station and I've
had that job for nine years and while I
worked for the Tanksley lab for almost
20 years I attended a lot of seminars in
this room and never really expected to
be giving one Here I am I actually have
something you might be interested in and
I'm very happy to tell you about the two
growth chambers that my crew designed
and built and I also want to talk about
why we think that these chambers should
be the ones that Cornell adopts as we
try to move away from the old chambers
that we're using now so understand what
we have now let's take a quick look back
at how we got here let me put on oh yeah
here we go
there's the prototype we've had growth
chambers at Cornell since 1964 for more
than 40 years
each department had their own chambers
that they controlled and that's how it
was not just four chambers but also four
farms and greenhouses each department
had their own chambers their own
specific greenhouses with their own
watering staff their own farms each with
a farm manager and staff and tractors by
2010 farms greenhouses and growth
chambers were taken away from
departmental control and given to the AG
Experiment Station to manage with the
idea that there would be more improved
efficiency and we reduced the
duplication of equipment and personnel
if you remember back then
Cornell like the rest of the country was
trying to recover from the economic
recession of 2008 and so they were
looking for ways to save money and so
now
these facilities could be under one
managerial umbrella so to speak and
growth chambers could be looked at as
one single group and decisions could be
made about which chambers we might be
able to discard because a lot of them
were not only very old but also they
were very expensive to operate and a lot
of them weren't even used all that often
so we did discard about 34 chambers in
the first few years but at about the
same time we were also in having 33
chambers installed at Weill Hall so we
were pretty sure we weren't gonna short
ourselves a growth chamber space by
throwing away those old ones also for
some of the old chambers that were still
in big demand we got a chance to
retrofit them by replacing some of the
less efficient parts 22 old walk-in
chambers that are out at the Kent post
lab that area got new lighting and
computer controls thanks to a grant from
NYSERDA which is the New York State
energy resource & Development Authority
and that retrofit worked out really well
the Chamber's got twice the light
intensity at half the operating cost my
Sirte was so happy that they immediately
came back with another grant and we got
a chance to put new lighting in a lot of
our region chambers
still
third grant was forthcoming right after
that and they told us that they would
buy us six new chambers if we would
agree to throw away ten of our least
efficient ones and the chamber crew had
already done energy analysis on most of
our chamber models by then so we knew
exactly which chambers were the least
efficient and we were all too happy to
throw them away and today those six
chambers that NYSERDA bought us are in
operation at Weill Hall so let's take a
look at some of the hundred and twenty
five chambers that we currently are
using the 1960s brought us the first
thirty-five chambers in a collaboration
with dr. Arthur Watson Dimmick of the
plant pathology department and the
environmental growth chambers company or
EGC and these chambers are still in use
today down at the Ken post lab or new
and secretary endemic lab also the
growth chamber crew was established at
this time to maintain these chambers and
they were based out of the plant
pathology department that a lot of slide
change is coming up here in the 70s all
the other departments wanted their
chambers to so agronomy which crop and
soils was known back then and plant
breeding plant biology and horticulture
they invested in about 40 chambers
they were mostly reach-in chambers from
the shear corporation a large space had
already been designed and built into
that nugu Terman lab that was built out
on the edge of campus back then and
about half the chambers went to goo
termen others went to Bradfield and
plant science and some may have even
found their way into individual labs
the chamber crew which whoops that's
went too fast there the chamber crew
which was still under Plant Pathology
was asked to maintain all of these new
chambers as well and at that time we
started charging fees to raise money to
buy spare parts for the chambers this is
a slide of the Bradfield chamber room in
one of its better years if you've seen
it recently it doesn't really look that
good anymore so over the next few
decades additional chambers were sort of
added to the fleet here and there may be
a professor would write an equipment
grant or brought chambers with them when
they came here from another university
then in 2000 or there abouts Emerson
hall was renovated to include a large
chamber room in the basement where 23
conveyor and growth chambers were
installed and they would serve the
research projects in the Bradfield
Emerson in plant science area
these were state-of-the-art chambers
they had a central computer and digital
controls and humidity which was new for
chambers back then at this point all of
the chambers that Cornell now had were
the traditional kind of chambers in the
sense that temperature control was
achieved through compressors and
refrigeration for cooling and electric
heaters for heating that's the
traditional style and it still is the
traditional style in most places in
tooth
in nine while Hall was built a large
room was set aside in the basement to
house growth chambers and today there
are 34 chambers at while used by faculty
and grad students and these chambers are
pretty unique they're unique because
they don't use compressors or electric
heaters to regulate temperature like all
the other growth chambers this building
was designed so that campus chilled
water and building reheat water
circulating in pipes overhead would be
used to regulate the temperature inside
the chamber valves would send hot water
and cold water into separate coils
inside the walls of the chamber and fans
would circulate air past those coils now
here's a we took the panel off of one of
the wild chambers to reveal what's
inside obviously the fans and here are
the two coils that are inside the wall
and this system repeats itself on the on
the opposite wall this method is much
more energy efficient than the
traditional way of regulating the
temperature in a chamber the wild
building architects Cornell project
managers and Doug Keefe from the AC in
our shop got together with the Percival
scientific engineers to design this
system and it works really well the
temperature is usually maintained to
within a few tenths of a degree of the
set point and the people who got
together to design this really knew how
much energy was going to be required by
this many chambers so they designed a
system that really reduced the amount of
energy but even though the it works
pretty well at saving energy there are
some other problems with these chambers
the most damaging problem is that the
the water system is located on the roof
of all those chambers
the plastic plumbing fittings that are
part of the hot water supply and return
system are located on the top and these
plastic fittings are rated for a
temperature of a hundred and forty
degrees but somebody must have forgot to
ask the wild people what the temperature
of their water was because it's at a
hundred and eighty degrees that led to a
few problems after the first year or two
he started getting cracks in those
fittings and water would leak out and
eventually find its way over the side
walls of the chamber or work its way
into the Lightcap where all the wiring
was for the lights and the ballasts and
that mix did not go well let me tell you
water would eventually drip through the
light barrier and it would appear to be
raining inside the chamber this happened
you know quite a few times or water
might flow right through down the top of
that control cabinet and short out the
electrical components on its way down so
once at 3 o'clock in the morning one of
those plastic fittings broke completely
in half and it sent a geyser of hot
water up to the roof of the the ceiling
of the room where that water fanned out
and it rained down and all the adjacent
chambers we had to find a valve way
upstream to kill the flow because we
couldn't get anywhere near there the
water is a hundred and eighty degrees
and you don't want any of that so we
eventually shut the water off and about
five or six years ago I was up on the
roof of one of those chambers sponging
up the water after another fitting break
and my boss heard what had happened
again and so he came down to check it
out and while I was up there when I saw
him come in the room I yelled down at
him hey we could do better than this at
half the price I'll be
see I was frustrated again but I really
didn't expect anything to come from it
but it wasn't long after that I started
getting questions like you know what
exactly would you do to make it better
and having listened to what the crew was
telling me about fixing these problems
and listening to them after they fixed a
lot of the other chamber problems that
we would have I knew that they knew
exactly what it would take to make a
better chamber you know which which
components last longer which ones are
more reliable they had been dealing with
chamber failures for years so who better
to come up with a lasting solution than
the people who are having to deal with
this every day so we had a few meetings
which eventually led to a meeting with
the director of the Cornell experiment
station the crew described how they
would make a very efficient and durable
growth chamber and at the end of the
meeting we were asked to provide an
estimate as to how much it would take
how much it would cost to build a small
prototype to sort of prove the concept
after we found a source for a nice
insulated box and found prices for the
best components that money could buy
because I don't want cheap components
that'll just going to fail we figured
that it would take about twenty thousand
dollars to purchase all the parts and
now bear in mind that a commercially
available chamber of this size will
probably cost some between 75 and 80
thousand dollars by the time it's
delivered and installed so once we got
an account number we started ordering
all the parts it took months to get
everything the insulated white box took
over six months because we tried to
order it during their busy season and we
also needed them to make some custom
modifications the door is normally
located in the center of this
side of the box and we needed them to
move it to the right and down so that we
had room to put the control cab and so
we had to wait for their slack time so
they could retool their production line
you've you've seen these boxes often you
go to the supermarket there's plenty of
them there they all say ice on the side
so I just asked them to send me one
without the decal the control system
took months to get all so we went with
Argos and each one of those can cost up
to $10,000 each depending on the
components that you would want to have
in any particular situation this is the
same company that has controllers and
most of Cornell greenhouses now they
have lifetime support for their
equipment which is kind of rare and
growth chamberland because if you've got
a commercial chamber most of them
stopped providing support free their
controller after about five years and
then you have to buy used parts or you
have to buy another controller for
thousands of dollars and you know when
we got 125 chambers I don't feel like
spending thousands of dollars for each
one to upgrade their controller so Argos
their system can call me text or email
me if there's a problem and I can log in
at home find out what the problem is or
I can adjust the settings of any chamber
right from my office desk or right from
home so it's very convenient all the
other parts that we needed were readily
available I can even get some of them
overnight and free shipping overnight to
the main parts are really one pump two
heat exchangers two valves two coils a
few fans and a couple of fluorescent
fixtures the insulated box was set on a
pedestal a sort of metal frame and that
brought the box up to a comfortable
working height
but still allowed it to pass underneath
doorways so wherever we intend this
chamber to go we sort of have to walk
that route and measure you know will it
fit in elevators can it fit through
doors these pedestals also have wheels
on them and leveling feet so we can just
roll it to wherever we need it to go the
pedestal also provides space underneath
the chamber for all the plumbing
so no more plumbing on top of the
chamber we learned our lesson and we
also didn't put plumbing along the sides
in the back of the chamber either that
way these chambers can be stacked side
to side and back to back to maximize the
number of them we can fit into a room
because most chamber rooms that we have
around in different buildings are really
not big enough
this way we can really pack them in so
that was the idea there
if repairs are ever needed we just need
to take that panel off and we can get to
all the working working components but
so far we haven't had to repair this
chamber it's been more than four years
since it was built and it hasn't stopped
working yet and I've replaced the light
bulbs once it's hard to avoid doing that
but that's been it and this chamber is
very energy efficient we took the basic
concept of the percival design using the
chilled water and the building reheat
water to regulate the temperature and we
approved it a little and here's how we
did it I want to think another
look at the wild coils here this is a
wild chamber here we have a coil for hot
water and a coil for cold water when the
chamber needs to warm up a valve would
send hot water into the hot coil and air
would blow past that warmed coil and
bring warmer air into the chamber but
just before the chamber reaches the
desired temperature the computer control
system tells the valve to close and the
very hot but there's still a lot of hot
water in this coil that's gradually
going to cool off but before it does
that temperature in the chamber
overshoots the setpoint so now to
compensate for that the controller tells
the cold valve to open up and send cold
water into the cold coil and now this
coil is battling this coil for the
setpoint temperature and that sort of
battle just keeps going on and on it
kind of lessens over time and the
overshooting kind of diminishes a little
bit but it's still not as efficient as
it could be well I don't know if you can
see the red very well hopefully you can
this is a graph of that temperature
battle the yellow line is the setpoint
line and right now the chamber at
eight-thirty the Chamber's coming out of
day setting and wants to be at 17 C for
the duration of the night so the water
cold water is going into the cold coil
it drops the temperature but look how
far it overshoots and here the hot coil
is getting more water and it's coming up
here and now the cold coil comes on and
this just keeps on going that's you know
this is an exaggerated example sort of
usually it's not a full degree above and
below the set point but the slide is
there kind of to demonstrate what's
going on
the chamber crew thought seeing this
kind of thing happen all the time that
if the water going into the chamber was
already at the set point that you want
the chamber to be at the chamber would
only need one set of coils and not two
and the temperature would become much
more stable and that's exactly what
happened
but first when we built the prototype
and tested it the valves that we thought
were gonna do a really good job didn't
it turned out that the valve it when you
programmed it to open the minimum it
would open with 7% of its full capacity
and that was too much it sent too much
hot or too much cold into the system at
any one time so we had to start looking
for another valve and we eventually
found a magnetic valve with it would
only open a very small amount and that
just let a little bit of cold or a
little bit of hot into the system at any
one time now this chamber maintains the
temperature to within a few hundredths
of a degree of the setpoint that redline
now lays down right on top so that was
the key is finding that magnetic valve
here's a basic schematic of the plumbing
system there are three things in
constant motion at all times on this in
our system this circulating pump just
keeps that water flowing from inside the
chamber from outside the chamber to
inside the chamber through the coils
where the fans blow the air past and
then it goes back out again and gets
recirculated all the while these sensors
located at various points along the line
are figuring out just what's happening
with the temperature in that loop if
for some reason the chamber is warming
up a little bit the controller tells
this cold water valve to open and then
that opens a little bit of water flows
through the exchanger it comes out cold
and so the sensor determines that this
loop is now at the setpoint and it will
close that valve and now the temperature
remains at the setpoint if the chamber
is going from night time to day time and
needs to go up by 10 degrees the
controller will tell this valve to open
up a fair amount so that this loop then
becomes 10 degrees warmer and then as it
maintains temperature during the day of
these sensors are just kind of
monitoring the situation tweaking those
valves a little bit as needed to keep
that temperature where it's supposed to
be the system is a little bit more
energy efficient than the personal
chambers but it is a lot more efficient
than the traditional chambers that it
was built to replace here's a slide that
compares the two chambers obviously
that's the prototype there there is the
sheer 6310 both of those chambers are
the same amount of square feet and we
have 20 of those shears by the way
you're scattered around campus when we
analyze the electrical consumption of
these two chambers we set each of them
at the exact same conditions and then we
hooked up our power recorders and those
recorders ran for exactly 24 hours and
when it was done we were able to
download these graphs of the electrical
activity over that 24 hour period
so obviously the x-axis is time the
y-axis is watts and in this graph right
here the y-axis starts at zero watts on
this graph the y axis starts at 2000
watts so if I were to superimpose this
graph on top of this one that graph
wouldn't even start until what did i do
there there we go
this graph will
there wouldn't even start till halfway
so it gives you a visual idea of how
much less energy this thing uses when we
did all the math converting watts to
kilowatts and time to instead of 24
hours to one year this chamber
calculated out to $2,100 of electricity
per year this one 325 so that's the
savings of 85% this chamber is currently
being used for research at Weill Hall
and as I mentioned it's worked perfectly
for four years but you know this design
can work well for larger chambers too
and here is a slide of the chamber that
my crew just finished a few months ago
it's just ten times larger than the
original the interior square feet is a
hundred and it's designed to replace
those 22 walk-in chambers down at the
Democrat that are over 50 years old all
the lights in this chamber some of the
electrical conduit assemblies and the
vent louvers were all taken out of these
old 50 year old chambers and repurposed
into this one
those lights were part of a retrofit
that NYSERDA gave us you know about
seven or eight years ago they're still
doing well so we just reused them we got
another controller from Argos obviously
and this time we got the insulated box
from Bali which many of you probably
know is a large manufacturer of coolers
and they have a large variety of
different size boxes that we could get
so this time I told them to send me one
without their refrigeration no longer
required the total cost for parts for
this chamber was about 30
thousand dollars just twenty thousand of
it alone went for the controller in the
box we needed bigger fans because of the
size of the chamber it was so much
bigger than the other one but the
plumbing parts that we used for this
chamber are the exact same ones that we
used in small prototype the same pump
the same heat exchangers the same
magnetic valves and we're getting the
same result
this chamber works really well it
maintains very tight temperature control
usually about a tenth of a degree
centigrade now that's not as amazing as
what the smaller one does but the
smaller one is obviously a lot less
cubic feet to have to deal with other
than the fans in the side walls all the
working parts are located on the back of
the chamber each part is easily
accessible and easily removable for a
quick change out whenever that might
become necessary that's that's another
cool thing about these chambers the same
plumbing parts are used in every chamber
so we would only have to stock a few
parts to be able to be used anytime on
any chamber it's a lot different than
way it is now we have to have a large
part inventory the chamber is currently
working at GU Turman in room 139 and you
are welcome to check it out anytime
you're up there just feel free to walk
in there are plants in there but it's
not an experiment we just wanted to see
how different species would grow in that
chamber I should mention that
since gue Turman does not have the
infrastructure like wile howl to support
this kind of chamber we had to design it
with its own chiller see if I can get
that loud turning it off there's the
chiller and its own hot water heater so
the chamber you're kind of used with
that equipment until such time as we can
get a new infrastructure in order meant
to support this kind of system so now we
have a 10 square foot prototype and a
hundred square foot prototype chamber we
still need a few different chamber sizes
to accommodate all the different kinds
of research done here
for instance Bradfield in plant science
would probably benefit by having some
chambers that are designed for a rabid
abscess research with that in mind the
crew has now started to work on a third
prototype this one has 30 square feet of
growing space the the footprint of that
box is 15 square feet but the plan is to
put a shelf
right across the middle giving us two
growing spaces and each space would have
its own lights so that would be 30
square feet total it is possible that we
could use some white LED lights in this
chamber we're looking into it right now
we would get more energy savings from
LEDs and the lights would almost never
have to be replaced this chamber could
go 50 years and we may not have to do
anything to it
I guess that's wishful thinking I
suppose once this chamber is finished
we're going to move it to Weill Hall and
connect it up to that infrastructure to
test it and then maybe we'll look into a
fourth prototype this time maybe a step
in model with 50 square feet so that
would give us a 10 30 a 50 a hundred
square foot size chamber I don't think
we would need any different sizes than
that but we might want to vary the kind
of features that are available in these
chambers certainly the walkins would
benefit from having some HID lights
rather than just fluorescents for those
high light requiring crops and maybe co2
capability and some regions or steppings
would be helpful so we will look into
that
[Music]
so the 64 million dollar question is so
when are we going to start mass
producing these things well there's some
things we got to consider before we jump
into it and the first is who is going to
build them because we can't as long as
we're building a prototype we're okay
but once we start mass producing them we
are going to need to hire that out and
pay prevailing Union wage and I'm ok
with that I would like to collaborate on
this kind of thing but realize that the
cost to build them will probably about
double
our cost to build this this big one was
kind of deceiving it costs $30,000
actually that labor would about double
that but when you consider the Cornell
recently purchased a commercial growth
chamber of the same size for a hundred
and eighty thousand dollars the sixty
thousand dollar price tag for this
chamber is a little bit easier to take
the same thing applies for this small
chamber it's not exactly as dramatic
this one was twenty thousand dollars for
parts so if labor adds another twenty
thousand the forty thousand dollar cost
for this chamber still beats the
approximate eighty thousand dollar cost
to get a commercial chamber of this size
so now that we've broached the subject
of money the second consideration is
where are we going to get it right now
there are 57 walk-in and reach in
chambers in operation and they're
between 55 45 and 55 years old these
machines are being trusted with your
research obligations whether we want to
think about it or not those chambers are
gonna need to be replaced soon we really
should have been planning on doing that
20 years ago but I would like to replace
those 57 chambers with 62 of the
prototype style chambers and I recently
did the math 27 walk in chambers plus 35
reach-in chambers would cost about seven
point six million dollars if we purchase
them from a commercial chamber company
if we paid somebody to build them
ourselves it would cost approximately
three million dollars so we know that
somehow we're gonna have to get new
chambers pretty soon I'd like to save
4.6 million dollars when we do it
even a three million dollar price tag is
hard to swallow so I would like to do
this in a gradual way to lessen the
impact I would like to concentrate on
replacing all the chambers in one
building at one time and then do the
same thing in another building about two
to three years later until all the 50
year old chambers are gone that way the
cost is spread out over time and it's
something that we could budget for last
year to sort of help with finding a way
to purchase chambers the Cornell AG
Experiment Station set up a depreciation
fund for chambers and chamber fees were
raised 15% and that money goes into a
depreciation fund so in the extended
future we may have a way to do this in a
gradual way changing out chambers every
30 or 40 years but in the immediate
future we're still going to need a way
to find some money so somehow we'll get
it somewhere there's one more thing to
consider building these prototypes and
installing them at Weill Hall is very
easy that building is set up for them
unfortunately no other building is set
up that way right now but some buildings
would be easier to modify than others
Bradfield's for instance there's already
access to chilled water here same with
plant science we could insert a a heat
exchange
into the chilled water line in the
mechanical space directly behind the
chamber room and then plumb in a
dedicated loop from that chilled water
right into the chamber room and do the
same for the building reheat water that
way all the chambers in that room could
be served with this infrastructure and
it would be not near as big as doing say
a while hall or a GU term and the rooms
are much bigger there so campus chilled
water is just not available everywhere
it's not available it can poster in
Sector E maybe someday but it's probably
never going to be available out at GU
termen so in that kind of situation we
would have to install a large chiller to
generate the amount of chilled water
that's going to be required to serve a
room full of chambers the infrastructure
there would have to be completely redone
and that is obviously that would be
expensive but at GU Turman if 40
chambers are served by this one
infrastructure that kind of spreads the
cost out a little bit it makes it a
little more acceptable and when you
factor in the savings you would get by
building these chambers here combined
with the energy savings you get every
year for the life of the chamber the
payback rate on that investment of
infrastructure it looks a little bit
more reasonable and we've shown these
chambers to people who are in a position
to make projects like this happen and
they were very impressed with the
accomplishment of the chamber crew I
mean look at that thing it's gorgeous
well if you like chambers but so they
were impressed with it they but they
also understand all the things that they
have to consider before they jump ahead
with this kind of project in the end you
know there are many many priorities that
need attention to Cal's
and growth chambers are just one of them
so I want to show you who's responsible
here there are two people responsible
above all others for the design and
construction of these prototypes and
that's Bob Wilson on the left and mark
Daly on the right they did the whole
thing from start to finish it's their
design charles duffy the third member of
the chamber crew also helped out by
contributing ideas to its design and he
and Bob would bounce ideas off each
other for many years and those ideas
eventually led to coming up with this
this chamber crew is really the only
reason we can still use 50 year old
chambers here they really know how to
fix them Andy lead and I also
contributed a little bit to the design
but it was primarily Bob and mark who
brought this concept to a reality I also
want to thank Peter paradise he was
responsible for providing the funds for
us to build the large prototype that's
out accouterment until recently he was
the assistant dean for Cal's facilities
and now he is the associate dean for
Finance Cal's and another person who
deserves credit and thanks plenty of it
is Mike Hoffman he's the former director
of the Cornell Experiment Station about
five years ago he trusted this crew
enough to give us the money to build
that first prototype but he and Glenn
Evans were very supportive now yaanai
Rapp is the head of the Cornell
Experiment Station and he and Glenn
continue to give us the support we need
also John Conklin he works out a campus
area he's in the shop at campus area
farms and he fabricated all those
pedestals that the boxes sit on and last
but not least Anja Tim is an
administrative assistant at the Cornell
Experiment Station and she was very
essential because she showed me how to
put together a PowerPoint presentation
I've never done this before so also she
found a source for these these
translucent
CUA es logos that light up in the
windows of these prototypes when during
the daytime and that's a nice touch so I
appreciate her help yeah so that is
probably more than you ever expected to
know about growth chambers in your life
if you have any questions I'd be happy
to answer
[Applause]
Lisa what's the current occupancy rate
for kills users I would say it's in
excess of 95 percent I can tell you off
the top of my head which chambers are
available and it's easy because there
aren't very many that are available so I
might have five that are available
I'd liked the ideally I would like to
have 10% excess capacity so that people
don't have to be put on a waiting list
when they want to chamber there's no sin
in having a chamber sit idle I don't
think if it if it's ready and available
when somebody needs it and they can be
just shut off you don't have to sit
there and run all the time we can just
turn them right off can't really do that
with the old 50 year old ones because
those refrigeration units don't like to
be shut off they start leaking
refrigerant after a while any other
questions yeah we that question kind of
almost leads into whether we got a
patent on this or not so that we could
start a company and Cornell sent people
out here as soon as that first prototype
was built and they did all the research
and told me it's not patentable and I'm
basically I'd be open to anything that
gets us new chambers if Cornell wants to
start a business it'd be fine with me I
don't want to that time has come and
gone for me I think approaching
retirement age and I'm not ready to
start a business but I don't think my
crew isn't that interested in it either
but whatever we can do to help bring
more chambers here is fine with us
oh you know no problem
Jeff either one slide to show you the
energy savings between the prototype and
one of the other changes of the levers a
significant savings there is most of
that the heat exchanger chilled water
setup versus the situation our first
it's mostly there so but I'm just
thinking you hear three versus seven
seven million dollars doesn't take into
account savings right in energy you're
gonna realize there as well right those
two really should be added together to
get the full impact
what this thing every down between
universes speaking before them saying
Braddock enduring saying he didn't show
water yeah we could do that yeah we
wouldn't have to invest in a chiller in
this building right behind that chamber
room is chilled water pipes that we
could tap into
so I'd like to start in Bradfield just
convincing people who might or may not
have the money at the current moment
well I had heard that they're going to
upgrade the infrastructure in this
building so I sent a drawing off to
those people saying behind g12 Bradfield
could you insert a heat exchanger right
there
put a couple of valves in it that we can
we can just tap into that when the time
would come and then we could get the
chilled water so I was told that my
drawing went on to whoever's in charge
of that project so well see all this is
news to me yeah that's good
and Peter of course you care that is all
about that so well there's a grungy old
room in the basement bo6
that used to have more chambers in it
than it does now but I've figured out
that that room could fit 11 chambers not
just this size but the one with the
double doors on it we could fit 11 of
those down there and that would be
perfect for a rabid abscess research
where a lot of the people in that
building are doing that kind of work so
chilled water isn't far away from that
room and we could bring it in and Chris
Martin okay I mean this whole thing was
here but this is something she'd be
interested in well I'd be happy to
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu